I'm coming up on 10 years of being a
practicing doctor and I've had some
incredible patient encounters while this
patient encounters weird patient
encounters so I thought I'd share a few
of them right now let's get started be
whoop this story
um still haunts me to this day that it
happened in the way that it did because
it really shouldn't have went down this
way and this happened actually when I
was a student I was rotating at this
medical facility
and I walk into the room I'm like what's
going on you guys are pretty banged up
and they said well we were involved in a
car accident coming back from Florida
the husband was behind the wheel of the
car and actually fell asleep and ended
up crashing the car at a very high rate
of speed they said well we think we're
okay and we kind of went to the local
hospital where we crashed they were
somewhere down south but we felt like
they didn't do a full evaluation that we
thought was satisfactory so we came here
and I see that the male patient has a
fractured clavicle the female patient
has a broken humerus and so much so that
I think it damaged her nerve plexus
because she has a wrist drop there was
significant injury that was visualized
on all of these tests there were hip
x-rays abdominal CAT scans but the one
thing that wasn't there which shocked me
was a head CAT scan so I go back into
the the precepting room which is where
you talk to all the senior doctors and I
said look let me dig into this case I
really looked through all the scans I
looked at all the records the intake
forms and I see that the female patient
is on Plavix that's a blood thinning
medication she's on a blood thinning
medication just got into an accident at
a high rate of speed and did not get a
CAT scan this is definitely wrong I
present the case to my attending my
attending as a family medicine doctor
firmly agrees says I cannot believe is
outraged that we're absolutely got to
get them to the ear the next day I come
into work and I'm so curious to see what
has happened I'll open the medical
record to see what happened with this
case and I see that those patients left
against medical advice meaning that they
signed a form saying that I don't want
to be here that I'm leaving before the
doctor has cleared me to leave
the ER doctor said that the family
medicine doctor doesn't know what
they're talking about you're fine now
it's been over 24 hours since your car
accident because you're not showing any
symptoms there's no use to getting a CAT
scan and that you're going to be fine
and I'm like look
this is going to sound really annoying
but I think you should go back to the ER
they're like well look can we talk to
your senior physician I'm like he's not
here today but as soon I'm telling you
you really should go to the ER because
you're on blood thinners your husband
wasn't in great shape either I really
think both of you need to get scanned
and because I have another attending
physician that's here right now in the
hospital we can meet you and get you
scanned even if the ER doctor this time
says no
the female patient has actually been
admitted into the neuro ICU because it
turned out turned out that after getting
the CAT scan she was actually having a
very slow bleed into her brain as a
result of being on the anticoagulation
medicine Plavix and it had to do an
emergency craniotomy which is with them
opening up the skull and relieving the
pressure and had they not done that she
could have died and probably would have
died to be honest I was like
oh my god did I just save a life because
of all this
the craniotomy went well the neuroicu
stay went well everyone ended up
recovering all this stuff had a very
happy ending but because this was what
we classify as a near-miss we actually
had to file reports with our system in
the computer where we report these near
misses we met with the head of the
emergency department to talk about why
this happened and created policies to
make sure this never happens again I was
working in my clinic late one evening
and what I like to do before I start my
hours is actually look through who's on
my schedule look through what's going on
in their medical history to make sure
I'm not missing anything when I walk
into the room and I saw on my schedule
at the end of the day was a young
patient a young girl that was coming in
uh for like a sore throat so I didn't
think anything of it when I look later
in the day that patient switched to a
different patient a male patient with a
very similar name
when I walked into the room I right away
got a little bit of a strange sense that
something else was going on because the
patient was acting a little bit reserved
so I said let's let's investigate I
introduced myself I started asking the
questions and the patient abruptly
abruptly shifts the conversation and
says doctor I have to admit the real
reason I'm here I'm aware that your mom
has passed
and I'm like thinking where is this
possibly gonna go well I'm here because
I actually have a message
from her to you and I think it's really
important that I share it and at this
moment I'm really confused because I
don't know what to do I want to be
professional at the same time I know
that this patient is being
unprofessional and I don't know exactly
what my next steps should do so I kind
of gathered myself and I said
I appreciate you doing that but I am
here working and I have to take care of
patients who are having illness and need
my help while I'm appreciative of the
message I'm not interested and I have to
move on to the next patient I hope
that's okay with you
and to my surprise the patient was
that's perfectly fine I'm okay with you
doing that but I just want to say that I
needed to get that off my chest and
share that with you
totally through me but we moved on and
we kept taking care of other patients I
actually have a patient who I've been
taking care of for many years who
happens to be a doctor
and we start talking about their health
they tell me that everything is in
normal working order they don't smoke
they drink socially very rare drug use
they are sexually active intermittent
protection this is a male patient by the
way look at the lab work and I see that
it's all it's all looking good and then
something happens which I really wasn't
prepared for I see that the HIV fourth
generation test flag positive first of
all it's fairly accurate there's not
many instances where this test is
inaccurate and they had a very big
reaction tears and I understood why
tears were coming they were very worried
they didn't know what was going on they
weren't sure if this was a sexual
exposure or if this is a patient
exposure would I talk to them I said
okay look this is a test that needs to
reflex to other tests and it's likely
that those tests are still pending so
let's wait for those tests to come back
which then allows us to understand what
um type of virus this is and again we're
talking about human human
immunodeficiency virus which if
untreated can progress to AIDS they
obviously were very emotional about I
said look go home I should have the
results by the day I'll call you at the
end of my work shift
I see that the rest of the tests are all
negative I in my history of being a
doctor have never really seen a false
positive for this fourth generation HIV
test in this instance I said before I
call the patient back I probably should
do some really thorough research to give
them answers why this was a false
positive so I pull up up to date which
is one of our most used resources as
family medicine doctors which we use as
a reference tool and the the thing tells
me that the HIV fourth generation test
which has changed since my education
which was third generation Test Now can
flag false positive in some very
specific instances one is pregnancy
two if they are taking HIV medications
three is if they have an autoimmune
disorder
and then cave number four
if they've recently received a flu
vaccination apparently and this is
something that I even learned in that
moment there is evidence that when a
patient receives a flu vaccine that they
actually develop some antibodies that
react with this agent on the fourth
generation HIV test which can make it
come up positive but then if you check
the rest of the test they will all come
up negative and knowing that this
patient of mine is a health care
provider knowing that I can look into
the record and see when they've had
their flu shot five weeks before they
had their flu shot and there we go we
had my answer so I called the patient
back told the patient good news they
obviously requested to be retested just
to make sure we rechecked in a few weeks
and everything was totally negative at
that time but that's why it's really
important that when you're ordering
tests you know what to do if it's
positive negative or even if you don't
know what to do you know where to look
to get those answers so uh the other day
I had a patient who's around 40 50 years
old
and they say doctor like I've finally
been able to lose around 25 pounds we've
been talking about them losing weight
for some time they finally lost the 25
pounds and I haven't seen them in quite
a bit of time so I was sharing in their
celebration I was like great job so
happy for you how did you lose the 25
pounds the patient said you know what I
just haven't been doing anything I just
happened to lose 25 pounds and I was
like wait wait you've lost 25 pounds
without trying like unintentionally and
they said yeah how long of a period of
time did this happen and he goes it's
been about a month five weeks maybe
now all these alarm bells are going on
in my head and I started asking about
other symptoms
well you know I've been a little bit
tired a little stressed out with work
but the fact that I'm losing weight
makes me happy the patient also mentions
some night sweats I also looked at the
patient during the physical exam The
Tint of their skin color was a little
bit off than their usual because I've
seen them for three years I felt like it
looked a little bit more pale I need to
order some tests to give me reassurance
that you're not really sick
the patient has a slight abnormality in
their complete blood count and it was
like so mild that maybe some doctors
look at it and say no big deal I didn't
like the whole story I felt like there
was something more so I I told the
patient that I was feeling this way and
I said look I think we should get a scan
and rule out that there's nothing else
going on something more Sinister like
cancer what does the insurance company
do denies the scan we send in my
paperwork they deny my paperwork so now
I have to get a prior authorization I
called the insurance company on hold
talk to one person another person and I
finally get a peer-to-peer which is I'm
talking to someone who's also a medical
professional I tell them I have a
patient here that's lost 10 percent of
their body weight will you take it upon
your soul your back to say that if this
patient has cancer and we miss it
because you denied the thing the test
that it's your fault they said oh well
you know if you're worried about cancer
maybe we can get it approved I'm like no
maybe please get disapproved I'm giving
you the rationale this makes a lot of
sense they said fine
and sadly enough my patient turned out
to have a lymphoma and this is not a
story that's happened a long time ago
this is something very recent we were
able to get them in with an oncologist
very rapidly the oncologist sent me a
message in the electronic health record
uh thanking me for doing this and
speeding the whole process up because
we're able to get the patient in quite
early I'm hoping for a good outcome I
don't have all the answers yet but
because we're able to do this and argue
for the patients on the patient's behalf
I'm hopeful we get a better outcome
I actually had a patient with foot pain
that got way worse way more of a
complicated case click here to check
that out and as always stay happy and
healthy
[Music]